- Alright y'all, we're
back celebrating women
smashing glass ceilings
in sports, on the field,
the courts, and the sidelines.
My next guest is a remarkable
13 year old athlete
who plays softball,
basketball,
volleyball,
and soccer, cause, well why
the hell not? (Kelly laughs)
(audience laughing)
All while maintaining a
4.0 grade point average.
So she's every parent's dream.
But her ultimate dream is to
be a sports ball color analyst,
so check her out in action.
- Hi, I'm McKenzie Kesh
and welcome to Dodgerton.
The Dodgers are the top
team in MLB without a doubt.
So you can't argue with that.
When the Dodger's whoop-it,
they do not do their job.
The Women's National
Team deserves more money
than the men's.
The men's, how many world
cups have they been to?
Less than the women's.
What, did they qualify?
No, they didn't.
And the NCAA Men's March
Madness Tournament underdogs
have been winning and
busting people's brackets,
including mine.
(inaudible)
Don't get me started.
- What's so good about Lakers?
- What's so good about Celtics, hmm?
I'm McKenzie Kesh signing off.
(audience claps)
- Oh my god. You are great.
Everybody say hello to McKenzie!
(audience cheers)
You are so great.
And hilarious, by the way,
your timing is so many,
so much passion.
And your videos, I love it.
Have you always loved sports?
- Yes. I can't live without sports.
I love sports for as
long as I could remember.
I started playing baseball
when I was five years old
and I was the only girl on my team.
And I was just as good as all the boys.
- I love your confidence. Oh my gosh.
So why do you dream of
being a color analyst
and just for inquiring minds want to know,
what is a color analyst?
- Well, there are two
types of broadcasters.
There's a play-by-play analyst
who basically tells you
exactly what's happening
in the game.
And then there's a color
analyst, what I want to be,
and they share your facts
and opinions about the game
and give you more insight of their stories
because they normally have
played the game before.
- Yeah. And give them little more sass.
- Yes.
Cause that's what I love
about you, McKenzie.
Well, we have two sports
ball analysts who know all
about your skills and passion.
They want to meet you.
Do you want to meet them?
- Yes, please.
Okay. Well, one is a
two-time WNBA all-star.
She still plays for the Sparks
and she's an NBA analyst for ESPN.
The other is an Olympic gold medalist
and a major league
baseball analyst for ESPN.
They're each a whole lotta woman, y'all.
All right everybody, say
hi to Chiney Ogwumike
and Jessica Mendoza!
(audience claps)
Wait, where is she? (Kelly exclaims)
- Oh my goodness. Oh my god.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Chiney] I got you some gifts.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Chiney] Hey girl.
- Hi.
- [Chiney] You are so amazing.
- [McKenzie] Thank you so much.
- [Chiney] And so I got you some presents
from the LA Sparks.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yes. So, I have to ask you.
Chiney, I'll start with you.
What do you think of McKenzie's talent?
She's hilarious.
- I wish I was you when I was younger.
I mean, your personality
jumps off the screen.
You are confident.
You're intelligent.
You've got it made.
- [McKenzie] Thank you so much.
- Amazing.
- It means so much coming from you.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
What about you Jessica?
- Oh my gosh.
Hi, McKenzie. I love all
the photos by the way.
How are you?
- I'm doing amazing.
- [Jessica] Oh my gosh.
Chiney shows up with like a gift bag,
I'm like, "Dang it. I want
to do that." (Jessica laughs)
Oh my gosh.
I had to point out one thing though.
You are honest.
Oh my gosh. I love it.
You are so real.
Do you know what?
It takes women like decades
to be able to find their voice
and to be able to say it loud and proud.
And you just call on out
that men's world cup,
"How many world cup does the men have?"
Oh I love that.
- It is my favorite
part of the whole video.
"How many? Oh, oh that's sad."
"How many of the women won?"
(Kelly laughs)
So here's my thing.
So you each have something
to tell McKenzie, right?
So you want to go for it, Jessica?
You want to talk first?
- Oh yeah.
So first of all, Mackenzie,
we need to hook up.
We need to beat up. I heard
you talking about the Dodgers.
I know that's your team
and I want to be able to hang
with you at Dodgers stadium.
So I know that you're
in Southern California.
So you and I have got to meet up.
If you have any questions
the fact that your softball or baseball.
I play baseball first
too girl, and I love it.
I feel like our paths
are definitely gonna keep connecting.
- [McKenzie] Thank you.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
- [Kelly] She's fighting the tears.
So what about you, Chiney?
- Can I hang out with y'all
at Dodger stadium too?
Jess, isn't it open
invitation? (Jessica laughs)
Okay, good.
I can't let my team
- You should get my some Sparks shoes.
- [Chiney] Okay yeah. There we go.
I can't let my team go to the dust.
So I would love, once we have fans,
for you to come court side
and watch the LA Sparks play.
That'd be so much fun.
You could rock your jersey.
You've got your own custom Jersey in here.
And working for ESPN, I'd love
if you'd be able to
shadow me on my radio show
and just hang out with the guys
and give them the business.
You could be like our guest correspondent.
- That would be amazing.
Thank you so much.
Thank you Ms. Jessica.
- Oh my God. I love you. She
said, "Thank you Ms. Jessica"
(Kelly laughs) Oh my god.
A big thanks to Play-by-play
sports broadcasting cams
for telling us all about McKenzie.
She's amazing.
And we're so glad we got to hang with you.
Can't wait to have you back
after those experiences.